hi um thank you so much for having me so
I came from a furniture background I got
my degree at the california college of
the arts and crafts I tended bar to put
myself through school I worked the
slanted or group for eight years and I
started making some syrups i started
making this old french syrup called
oranje now it dates back to the Middle
Ages there's countless versions from
across many many countries and it is one
of the ingredients in the original mai
tai I grew up in Oakland the original
might I was created at the first Trader
Vic's in Oakland in 1944 at the time
we're talking 2007 the only or job that
you could buy on the market was
typically a mixture of high fructose
corn syrup citric acid and almond
flavoring not made from actual almonds
at all so I started making the syrup and
we started sell serving traditional mai
tais to other bartenders who came to the
bar and soon enough people wanted to buy
it for their own bars so I started
making a couple other products including
a pineapple gum syrup it's a very
popular product of mine because as far
as i can tell them the only person who
makes pineapple syrup from actual
pineapples so we come to along now
non-profit organization dedicated to
long-term thinking they approached me
about opening a bar the way that they
termed it I unex tinct cocktails so for
an organization concerned with time it
seemed really appropriate why would they
want to open up a bar while they had
this beautiful space in Fort Mason they
have a number of very fascinating
projects that people weren't really
exposed to so here's this space on the
left you can see this is a prototype for
a chime generator it's part of a clock
that's being built into a mountain in
Texas where the mechanics are built to
last for ten thousand years Brian Eno
was one of our founders he created this
chime generators that every day for ten
thousand years a unique series of chimes
sounds so you could come and see this
project they work on a bunch of other
stuff unac stinking animals archiving
languages all that kind of stuff so you
could come into the space and kind of
see artifacts of these projects but you
weren't really engaged in it and they
wanted to create a space where people
were actually engaged in it so they
started looking at the idea of the three
in space so this is the space outside of
your home and your work where you spend
the most time and historically these are
places like coffee houses and salons so
at this point I'm really intrigued and I
accept the job of it so I learn about
this space now where this is located
itself was the original blacksmith shop
and forge for fort mason when fort mason
was military concrete floors you can
actually still see the imprint of where
the forge was including an event in the
ceiling and to me that's just so much
conceptual fodder right that's what
you're selling the product is booze but
the experience is the concept right so I
decided on the concept of time for this
bar is found it really appropriate for
the long now foundation so these are
just some samples and some things we
knew are going to be in the space and
this is what it looks like now so we've
been open since June we had this concept
of time right but then our subtext was a
place for conversation now that isn't
anything that you'll see printed
anywhere but we really wanted to create
this this place for conversation for
people to come in and talk with each
other and to engage with with the long
now so you can see we have a number of
different seating configurations that
chime generator we put glass on top and
turn it into a communal table you've got
a couple little intimate booths and then
a little private room in the back who's
door can be shut so the idea is that you
can interact with the space and with
other people on various different levels
the project was built via we called a
brick starter method so for a fifteen
hundred dollar donation you got a leader
of either gin or one of two whiskey's
that Lance winters from st. George
spirits made for us exclusively we keep
these up in the ceiling like a
traditional Japanese bottle keep we've
got Locker tags we've got everyone's
name on file and when you come in we'll
take it down you can drink it neat or
you can we'll make you a cocktail with
it now I was explaining to you this
chime generator is going into this
mountain in Texas now the first step to
building this clock was to drill an
enormous hole down into this mountain
then they cut away slabs on the side to
make a staircase we took sixth of those
labs and embedded them down for our for
our bar top yes this is Josh he's my
head barista he's awesome what this is
is three shots of the same
place so we have another Brian Eno peace
it's a digital painting he made it's a
series of images run with an algorithm
it's constantly kind of layering on to
each other and fading into each other so
you will never see the same thing twice
every time you look at it it's different
so again it's keeping with that time
theme we have the manual for
civilization which is our collection of
books which you can totally come in and
read when you're in town I really wanted
to keep that machine shop aesthetic
going I think there's an elegance to
kind of humble things so i worked with
taylor stitch in san francisco to make
these short sleeve blue chambray button
up shirts and aprons made from mattress
ticking that was hand I'd with walnut
hulls I love my industry so very much I
don't know why everyone's cocktail menu
looks the same and I really just felt
like we could have more than that a
cocktail menu could be so much more
comprehensive so instead of one list I
actually have a series of menus each one
is a family of drinks when keeping with
this time theme this meant that I could
have a daiquiri menu which is my doctor
menu is a moment in time this is the
five original daiquiris from bar la
florida and havana cuba when Hemingway
was hanging out there during American
prohibition this is a moment in time and
it's where the daiquiri comes from I
love that I love that and and just the
opportunity to be able to kind of share
that share that experience share that
story i also have a martini menu which
is all actual martinis dating from the
first martini 250 years ago up through
to a modern approach to a dirty martini
but being able to kind of route each one
in time or space or history this is a
welcome menu we printed it on ledger
paper the layout of the menu is such
that the story about each drink is on
the left i mean i fell in love with
cocktails because of the lore and the
legacy and the provenance of these
drinks and kind of how they had evolved
over time so i wanted to be able to
provide them so this is the
mother-in-law this is a traditional new
orleans hospitality drink and still to
this day you will find people in New
Orleans who will make this drink in the
morning and just have it there in case
anyone drops by they will have a
cocktail immediately ready and I love
that idea and i found the
is really sweet apothecary bottles any
basis glassware to me was very important
again that machine shop aesthetic most
of our glassware the bottoms are the
same thickness as the sides they're
simple but I really find elegance and
that kind of stuff this is a gimlet this
is probably what makes me a good
bartender what any drink the gimlet is
three ingredients so simple gin lime and
sugar but it's the way i manipulated my
separate the lime into zest and juice
and steep it for an hour and then it
takes two days to separate and then I
push it through a vacuum filter and it's
ridiculous and the reason that it's
cloudy is because of all the essential
oils that the lime that the lime zest
gives the drink so it Lucia's the way
absence does I'm very proud of that
drink this is a death in the Gulf Stream
this is an Ernest Hemingway drink
brought to us by a charles h baker jr
and this is the JP a martini 250 years
ago it was a white wine genever and
cinnamon so you can see how that evolved
to gin and vermouth I had a ceramics
custom-made this is telly ad on in West
Auckland so before we repainted in the
space the bottom half of the walls were
painted in this kind of dull British
racing green and they were going to
repaint it white so before they did I I
went and I took some of the wall and
brought it to the ceramicist and asked
if they could make ceramics in that
color so now that that color is no
longer on the walls we at least still
have some of that color in this space so
here's some shots of the barn now that's
just like looking head on into the bar
we've got now seats around the Ori so
you can engage with it while you're
sharing the space cafe during the day
and a bar at night so that's it thank
you